one of the completely baseless claims
that Republicans are making in response
to the Hammer attack on Nancy Pelosi's
husband Paul Pelosi is that this is all
the fault of Democrats defunding the
police and that prosecutors are too
lacks and that Democrat cities so-called
are extraordinarily dangerous this is
the line that they're coming up with the
truth is that this was a right winger
who didn't like Nancy Pelosi and wanted
to break her kneecaps so she would have
to be wheeled into the House of
Representative to send a message to
other Democrats you better be careful
your consequences have actions here is
Donald Trump's one-time acting uh
attorney general assistant Matt
Whittaker you guys remember this guy he
said we have to look at the bigger
picture how convenient forget about the
fact that David de Pape or the Pape was
a right winger anti-vaxx like Tim Poole
uh uh anti-semitic all this difference
forget about that
it's the bigger picture of democrat
crime in Democrat cities your reaction
to what took place uh to Paul Pelosi
yeah well obviously it's if as reported
it's a horrific you know uh invasion of
his home in in an assault on him uh and
it's you know political violence should
never and does not have a place in our
society we have to look at a bigger
picture Maria and that is is that San
Francisco is is crime riddled and a lot
of it is due to the lacks policies of
the local prosecutor and when you when
you take that context it's going to be
very interesting how this individual who
is charged with some serious crimes
whether he gets the same treatment of a
lot of the violent criminals right the
problem is they're going to treat him
more roughly than the other antifa BLM
whatever because this guy is maybe a
right-winger but maybe not understand
that this analysis is bogus uh Nancy
Pelosi and her husband weren't the
victims of a random home invasion
related to the broader crime situ
situation in San Francisco they were
targeted by a right winger for their
political views the lacks prosecution
whether you believe that's what is
taking place in San Francisco or not
um the the other one is the defunding of
police which hasn't happened this is a
specifically targeted crime and this is
a way of them trying to figure out how
do we blame attacks on Democrats on
Democrats themselves and understand the
incredible difference between these two
political groups you don't see
Democratic candidates with assault
rifles in their campaign ads you just
don't see it you don't see Democratic
campaign ads with Targets on Republicans
the way dating back to Sarah Palin and
much more recently we have seen
Republicans do and meanwhile I think
it's important to mention crime isn't
even actually up in San Francisco I I
know that they love to talk about this
just look up violent crime and property
crime and you will see that it it's just
it's just not up the the numbers are
very steady and even a little bit lower
than they were five years ago there has
been no defunding of the police in San
Francisco violent crime is just not up
and so even the premises on which which
some of these claims are based are
completely and totally untrue make sure
that if you watch our clips on YouTube
you're not just watching the Clips make
sure you hit that subscribe button it is
free every time you hit that subscribe
button Alex Jones grimaces Thank your
lucky stars every day you're not Dave
Pacman yeah
um there's nearly three million of you
that regularly watch our videos but are
not subscribed let's get to two million
folks hit that subscribe button we'll
take a quick break and be right back
I've had such trouble finding a great
razor where I am not cutting myself or
getting those Nicks on my skin which are
so common with the cheap disposable
razors you have to meet our sponsor
Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below